welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
joined of course
by why of course i mean we have a
different guest every week but it's
bobby lee and kalila
this episode is sponsored by draftkings
and
me undies how are you guys doing in
these strange
odd times
well you know living with her is like
living with miss hannigan from
annie um she's um very strict
um i haven't been to a grocery store i
haven't been to a
i've been to two gas stations um i
haven't been to a rave
and i haven't been to a strip club and i
haven't been
i haven't seen my mom wait hang on one
second
that's crazy talk he's a bad son
he's a bad son i have repeatedly asked
him check on your mother make sure that
someone sends her a grocery she's 80
years old
you're a bad son i text her every day
he texts her every day i text her every
day how long does the text interaction
last is it like hey how are you
and then you peace out or literally i i
i i can i i can read you some
interactions that we have we've had we
have it yeah
how long is this conversation well the
conversations are like this
so um she'll she'll always send me like
some sort of are these memes those are
um um they're just quotes they're quotes
so she'll say
have a great like a quote have a great
week ahead
wishing you all a great week filled with
smiles
happiness and all the good things in
life and then i'll just go i love you
mom please stay
safe out there don't get covered but
they're all like that i would just
one line i love you mommy love you mom
where is she getting oh
good night and she does meet yeah and so
kalila you think that's
inadequate communicating with his mother
um i do i'm more of uh
um i don't like pretty talk i like
what are you doing with your hands to
help her
navigate through a pandy so my thing is
like
[Music]
the panty so like with my parents
because like i have a fear of them going
even to the grocery stores i make sure
that food is always delivered to their
door
and they have produce and things like
that so they don't
they don't feel the pressure to have to
like step out weekly because they're old
so bobby does kalila like her parents
more than you like your
your mom ethan ethan don't be like that
don't be that don't buy
don't don't swallow the pill don't be
like that okay
all right you're supposed to be on my
side now check it out bro i'm always on
your side
thank you my mother even before the
pandy
okay wore a bts
mask right correct what's bts
it's behind the scenes as a k-pop group
yeah yeah so she's obsessed with the
k-pop groove right
and they wear a mask on stage she wore
the mask
you know before even the pandemic yeah
so i know that she's wearing a bts mask
is she wearing a mask oh because it's
for fashion
yeah so when she goes outside she wears
like this it looks like a darth vader
like
summer mask yeah before the pandemic
started she already had a whole
collection of masks
is it like an asian thing because i know
like asians like the mask is that
is it just like no that's that's so
that's so
like you to even ask that um well hold
on yeah are you
saying yes yes yes yeah well it's not
she my mother is asian but she's also
very eccentric so yes i think she
um it is kind of an asian thing yeah
you're right
does she wear can i ask you another
question what
does she wear gloves when she drives
yeah like michael jackson what is that
what do you mean what do you mean i've
just noticed that asian
no but asian women wear gloves when they
drive and i just find
i swear to god i mean how would i know
that she wears a glove otherwise
how would i know that
yeah she just um i don't know why she
wears i don't ask these questions
because
then you go down a rabbit hole right
you don't understand it's called a
fashion you know i mean she'll go into a
whole thing so it's like
i just kind of when i look at her
because she wears bandanas on her head
and funny glasses she wears like a lot
of scarves
it's the ajumma style the power clashing
like i feel like the power clashing was
made
made wonderful by older korean women
well i made her cry in hawaii well
before the pandemic started
their last interaction was a giant fight
and meltdown
in hawaii because he was really upset
that about her obsession with bts
so let me let me explain okay wait wait
what
okay go ahead let me explain okay so
there was a time where my mother and i
our phones were linked
because she she was on my i because she
wanted my itunes right
so we had she my email was attached to
her phone oh yeah so
all her photos would come down to my
photos right
and okay i'm not kidding you
she would screenshot two to three
thousand photos
of bts a day wait hold on are we really
talking about
bts the korean pop band so
obsessed really yeah when we gave her a
bts
stuff for christmas last year she cried
wait are you guys with me no i swear i
swear to [ __ ]
well i have a photo of her wearing a bts
mask
wait so she i can't believe what i'm
hearing that your
mom is a bts fan okay well because i
joked about it before and you act like
like no wow okay when i met said
bts that's what i meant oh wow okay yeah
yeah yeah this is real
wow this is [ __ ] real this is [ __ ]
real wow okay okay
so we're in hawaii right and and she
would stay in the hotel room
and we would be driving around and i was
with my brother and kalila
and i would look at my phone and i'd
spend maybe an
hour a day erasing oh no
you did 3 000 he has screenshots
and i i just snapped and i was like this
is going to stop
it's unhealthy right so we we raced back
to the hotel
and my mother sitting on the bed
screenshotting bts
and i think she's playing with her old
coochie oh
dude i know that's what i think i mean
that's the only thing
why else right why why is she saving all
these street shots she's going
okay okay and she's playing with her
coochie watching like looking at bts
like in my mind didn't you say like 80
80
yeah your 80 year old mom is a bts fan
how does that happen yeah
i don't know so what does she do with
all these screenshots
i don't well here she makes this is
where i had to play mediator because it
was a whole big family meltdown between
them
apparently she was crying by the time
bobby had actually confronted her
she was crying and she was like it sees
because i like to make these collages
because i am i'm a super fan she's army
and
she's army for sure what does that mean
bts army she is
yeah so she makes collages and then she
just saves them on her phone
it's like digital scrapbooking for her
to pass the time because she
believes what i'm hearing how is she 80
and she's so into all this stuff that
like
she's making she's actually a lot more
internet savvy than
most older people like she's able to
navigate
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
stop doing it stop [ __ ] doing it
okay crazy stop [ __ ] doing it so so
you guys that's what your take was to
your mom just stop
so i i walked in i go daddy this is
gotta stop
your [ __ ] mind what the [ __ ] is a bts
listen to [ __ ] you know beethoven
like
all people are supposed to listen to
like you know i mean like
you know beatles and she goes and then
she
[ __ ] starts crying starts crumbling
she takes the blanket of the [ __ ]
hotel bed and she covers
her body and she goes uh leave me alone
i like what i like and then she was
really sad
i think she said this she started crying
with under the blanket she was like
my joy is my joy yeah my joy is my joy
my joy is my joy
and go [ __ ] your joy you said that
yeah yeah yeah and then kalala was
taking a shower
and my and then we just sat there and my
mom's like underneath a blanket crying
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do right
because i kind of want to do like a
you know like a wwf just wrestling and
slam her body
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah like that's
how enraged i was but then i i'm like no
i should wait until klyla comes out
kalela comes out and she hugs her and
then she made it all better but i i
swear to [ __ ] god man well it's
because him and
him and his brother at this point it's
like she was in a corner crying and they
just
wouldn't relent and then now i realized
the root of it all
um i think that because the bts boys
represent
a complete opposite of everything bobby
is
and who he thinks he is he feels really
offended that maybe his mom
has this like finally has like a perfect
sun's on the screen
wait opposite in what way kalila well
like you know they're
i mean handsome
this guy right here young and pretty
yeah yeah yeah that's what it is that's
exactly what it is
does she like how you dress or does she
hate it like
you made the mullet yeah i mean yeah
[ __ ] dude what are you doing that's
still not bts bro
check it out bro dude first of all this
is pandy me
okay this is not this is not
civilization me
civilization me i i you know i put on
the the moisturizer and i put the
fancy cologne on and i wear nice clothes
but in
when no one's going to see me who gives
a [ __ ] i'm seeing you
i mean everybody's seeing i know this is
the first time i'm doing this okay you
know
you have a show so yeah i think that's
what it is my mom
right um is like all the other koreans
right that likes that's they like
polished good looking
you know shiny shiny objects and it's
like my brother and i
are like little pieces of cat [ __ ]
you know i mean we're like little pieces
of cat [ __ ] next to these shiny objects
and i guess i get [ __ ] offended that
you know that i'm not that
in the moment wow you've definitely
that's what it is yeah
i think i would be upset too that's so
right right
thank you but do you think bobby's uh
maybe bobby's on to something like that
he has some
right to be like why does she obsess
with these perfect little
korean dolls and and but like she
doesn't want to
like why does she need her son she wants
to [ __ ] them
yeah sure and and who doesn't yeah
no me too i would probably [ __ ] them
yeah but she does
she does often say though when you ask
her like why she likes them and she says
i feel like they are my
sons oh that's [ __ ] up
so that ain't right look don't clap
don't clap well i feel like we hit it we
just you know what something's [ __ ] up
you don't clap
yeah right
you don't stand up give him a standing
ovation you know what i mean so yeah
that's why wow she says she feels like
they're her son
yeah she feels a warmth towards them and
a pride as if they were her own son
yeah man people love bts it's an
incredible phenomenon
how how how uh
the whole phenomenon it's just it's
unbelievable you know
it doesn't do it for me i don't know
thank you i don't say anything bad about
them i'm not gonna say anything bad
because you know about them yes they're
able to infiltrate the army is really
uh a kind of uh a force on their own
and they're almost like a political
force really
they are they're a governing body
they're part of nato i actually i love
what they've done politically so i
i love bts
no i love bts really i think they're
super talented
maybe one song wait give me one song
ethan i i don't think bobby understands
quite what the army does at all or
what their influence is on even like
twitter and what are you able to do just
be careful
my favorite song is dynamite it just
came out two weeks ago
no i like all of them it's hard to
choose yeah yeah i like first of all
i know what the military is all right i
know what an army is all right because
i've seen platoon i've seen
saving so i get what it is it's an army
of people
that support you know i mean bts and
number two i have these dreams about bts
about you know do you ever see the human
centipede yes
yes yeah so i have a dream of they're
all surgically you know i mean
oh you know oh they're all [ __ ]
right right and then they're just
kidding through each other
so bobby do you ever see yourself maybe
do you have fantasies about joining bts
no because i i feel like here's the deal
i feel like i've tried i've tried to
carve out my own
thing you know i've worked hard that's
another thing i think i don't think my
mom respects me
mm-hmm yeah that's the thing so i've you
know
you know i you know i do game shows i do
podcasts
yeah i do sketch comedy i do stand up
absolutely
and she doesn't respect it you know
you know it's like you know hey you kind
of have a face i just want to know do
you think his mom respects his
profession
yeah but it's a typical you know asian
mom
relationship where it's like they they
won't give it up to their own kids like
god forbid you show any type of like
give your kids any real praise but but
she does
respect you and love you and is so
grateful for your existence there she
goes
no i'll give you an example so i was in
a movie
i was in a movie no i was in a movie
like
16 years ago it was called kicking it
old school
and it was a break dancing movie with
jamie kennedy okay
and it was it was premiere night there
was one theater
in arizona where my parents live where
it um you know premiered yeah you know
so my parents went to eight o'clock show
right
and my dad called me and he goes
there's nobody here and i go
what do you mean and he goes we in the
theater nobody here
and i go oh i'm trying to make me feel
bad yeah so i go oh watch it anyway
he goes if nobody here we don't watch
and they left
oh my god they left even your own they
never said
yeah they never saw it oh my god kind of
sad though because after the whole bts
meltdown in hawaii
he was trying to still kind of prove his
worth to his mom
and so and bts was coming to pasadena
before the pandemic happened bts was
supposed to be in pasadena this summer
performing and to try to um wield his
power
he said ma i can get you backstage to
bts like this
and then her eyes lit up and she was
like really kidding me
and then but i know what it was just a
flex it was you know yeah
could you really i called
yeah but you know so um that's why i
haven't really talked to her since
hawaii i text her every
day but i have to say that movie theater
anecdote is pretty sad that must've hurt
yeah it it hurt but you know they're
old-school koreans and you know
i think i know deep down inside that
they're you know
proud of me i guess maybe you know my
dad died but like my mom
still you know i don't think i was just
on a game show i don't think she saw any
of them
but um i mean it's fine it's fine it
reminds me of my dad too i
i get the old school vibe it's just like
it's just so different like you yeah you
just have to accept it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's the same
for me it's the same for me i always
growing up i always heard my mom praise
just about everybody
except for my sister and i think that
um it's even up until today it's like
you only really get
the true feeling on a birthday card
right once a year they spill their guts
on a birthday
party and you cry you have this moment
of like crying because oh my god your
mom
actually loves you and values you but
for the rest of the year it's a whole
lot of
pretty epic birthday cards
is it like a hallmark card that she
writes a ton on or is it like a whole
yeah
see my mom writes a lot my mom buys a
hallmark card and then she just writes
happy birthday
and then it's all about what's written
on the hallmark card
that's why i don't understand that [ __ ]
i go why does anyone care about cards
because it's like
i throw them out just sign it yeah but
well someone else wrote
that right yes yeah you don't mean that
you don't mean it yeah yeah they
probably never even read it
they just probably went to the [ __ ]
you know you know pharmacy or where they
got it from
yeah they go this looks colorful and
then you wrote happy birthday yeah but
ethan does your mom
give sprinkle you with love all
throughout the year
i don't know i think i mean yeah my
parents love me but but like they are
eli you better answer that you can be
honest about it
i think they do it's different for me
because they're different from
my family he thinks my parents are
[ __ ] crazy
no don't say that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's just so different but um
i i mean they do yeah they love it
they're just weird they do show it
it's just um for me it's different
there's a thing they listen
they're listening to this and they live
nearby us and they
like come over like once a week
ah so that's nice so that's nice but
like ela's embarrassed to say anything
it's no it's just that my mom is very um
affectionate and loving and
my dad was like the opposite so i grew
up with like
two polar like my dad was like never
said i love you
never never anything just
like that and then my mom is like the
opposite so
and then when it comes to hispanics it's
just totally different so i i don't know
how to put it in words
you know i don't want to say anything
offensive to them
does ethan say i love you to you yes a
lot
very effective yeah yeah do you say it
to kala yeah i'd say or every day i love
you a lot yeah yeah yeah yeah
how are you guys i don't
you guys like with covet and everything
you guys healthy you guys feel strong
i think we feel strong today i think it
was a little bit rocky in the beginning
i think with a lot of people trying to
match up
how you're going to approach a pandemic
because i
thought i had one plan and he had
another plan and we just weren't really
lining up with with how we wanted to go
about like safety and stuff like that
wow
yeah i'm glad that you guys are on the
safe side because i see so many people
who are not and it's just
crazy to me it's a crazy talk we all got
to do our part
because you know what the [ __ ] did i
agree i think that
those who can do their part and who have
the idea yeah exactly
yeah yeah and and the ones because
there's so many others who really can't
right right and it's like well let's
kind of try and offset the ones who
can't
by you know i mean i get people that
want need that need to survive
and then they need to pay bills and they
have to go to work i get all that right
but i don't get
like going to a beach party no you know
i mean i don't get that
you know so it's for me you know i um
you know a lot of people they don't
scoff but they think that you know
you know 200 dead 200 000 deaths
you know in the grand scheme of things
isn't
isn't a lot all right but for me it's
like i think about
each and every death how that affects
you know other
people's lives you know so it's just
like if to me
it is a lot it's a [ __ ] lot who's
going to say that
she meets a lot dude you know uh kovid
passed
cancer as the number two killer of
people in america now
yeah kills more people than cancer dude
yeah if you imagine 200
000 people in an arena just imagine that
they're all gone right i mean that's
heavy that's heavy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah hey bobby
um did you know that you have a 2.86 on
wiki feet
but
yeah and then i back up what the [ __ ]
yeah and i go why would you even [ __ ]
ask me that no no let me say something
okay
all right i'm not a foot model number
one i'm not a foot model
point eight six two point was it two
point eight six two point eight six
bobby
i'm trying to get your percentage
divided by five so okay
so it's just over 50 it's like you know
50.
that's a fail babe okay
yeah it's embarrassing i it's okay
let me say something all right number
one i'm not a foot model
number two i don't give a [ __ ] about my
feet never have never will
right because those are the the it's
like wheels
right right gilbert so like your wheels
right can be dirty because they're the
ones that are on the ground
right holding up the weight of the
[ __ ] car right
yeah yeah yeah in your car you go off
dirt
riding right they go you know whatever
they might do with the car
okay but the you know if you look at
someone's car it's pretty the wheels are
pretty dirty
yeah right and they don't wash them
every day no wash your tires of your car
yeah but do you no not every day
you haven't do you not address the nail
i do wash my feet every day though
why must you you're gonna get them dirty
again well like take a shower every day
right
oh i do okay you're right i do that
right and also eat ethan can i say
something okay
and and and i i have i have foot fungi
yes i know and i talk about that all the
time on people's podcasts
everyone knows that foot fungi you think
that's hurting your score
that's hurting my score yeah it's the
rumor bill because
who's taking photos of my feet if you go
there you can see the photos there's
like
10 of them like there's a lot or you
randomly show your foot
oh here you go can you guys see this
yeah yeah let me see
so click around oh okay can i
i can't yeah yeah so like
these people who who submit to wikifeet
they are
so sharp they don't miss a thing dude if
you show toe
they got it but i gotta tell you from
looking at it they don't look bad yeah i
don't know why they're being so harsh
thank
i have cute little yellow feet from the
sandals bro you're wearing sandals on a
talk show
[Laughter]
that's hilarious i didn't know wikipedia
existed when i did that
yeah see now you gotta live smarter now
i know yeah yeah
these guys will get you every time okay
so yeah so my feet don't look that bad
but you know for me
that's what i got in high school those
grades yeah it's just
par part i got all c's in high school it
doesn't make me feel bad yeah it's
consistent yeah
um what is your what is yours on
wikipedia it's ridiculous
well i'm glad you asked
here go ahead and pull it up whoever did
that i don't know who did that
oh yeah go ahead 5.46 out of 5.
i have a beyond perfect score
wow pretty ridiculous look at that
beyonce all right so all right okay so
can i ask
i honestly i'm being self-conscious
about it
and i want to ask everyone listening
okay
what does one do to get a higher score
that's
dude i feel like i feel like it's too
late no go
no i this is you want to know how i did
that because i just want to go
because every time i have a guest on i
bring it up and i tell all my fans go
give me five stars on wiki feet
and then when i there's people i don't
like like there's this guy keemstar it
was a piece of [ __ ] on youtube
i said go give him one star on wiki feed
pull up keemstar's wiki feed
ian this is how i get back at people
go give bobby lee a five star on wiki
feed
bobby deserves a five star you guys yeah
they'll make it home listening
you want to see what happens to my
enemies keemstar yeah one out of five
stars
you see what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
so
so everyone everyone listening to me i'm
gonna do a plea and i'm gonna get
emotional okay so and you go ahead
right now okay so dear fans and dear
people listening okay
you may not know me okay but i'm
desperado
i'm in deep panic mode please you know
my
i think i've been judged because based
on the photos right i don't think the
score
equates to that right so please i beg of
you
give me a higher score and and it'll
make it'll make my pandemic
um far more um i'll feel much much
better yeah yeah yeah so please please
help me please help me
it does feel good convincing yeah yeah
it's convincing thank you yeah they'll
do it so sorry to interrupt
a break do you remember that
bobby you got a break no that was a
sound bite you remember the last time
you were on you're
selling a really emotional story and
then dan interrupted you
because that that's like a meme on our
show now and so we use that sound bite
all the time of dan interrupting you
play it again so sorry to interrupt we
gotta go to break
we play that sound bite all the time
look at that is that dan right there the
photo i just saw
the picture i don't know what you're
saying
oh and then play the other one
thanks dan yeah we play that one all the
time there he is again
yeah thanks dan actually do we need to
go to break yeah that's actually true
okay we so we're gonna go to break
do you have anything to say bobby before
we go to break i just said that
okay no i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
okay so
sports are finally back in particular
football is back
and draftkings the leader in one day
fantasy sports is putting you
back in the center of this weekend's
action with over 8
million dollars up for grabs across all
of their contests
to kick off the season draftkings is
giving new users a
free shot at one million dollar top
prize with your first deposit
when you use code h3h3 during sign up
get in on the action now they do
now in all caps and exclamation that's
why
that makes sense accurate
i'm just trying to give the i just want
to do a good read for them
draft your lineup now now
and feel the sweat like never before run
every pass
every run catch means more with a
draftking lineup it's simple all you do
is pick your lineup stay under the
salary cap and see how your team stacks
up against the competition nothing adds
to the sweat of watching the game quite
like having a shot at a million dollar
top prize draftking
has paid out over billions billions of
dollars
to winners since 2012 so they know a
thing or two about cold hard cash
ela download the draftkings app
now and use code
h3h3 for a limited time new users can
get a free shot at one million dollar
top prize and compete for over 8 million
dollars in prizes across all contests
don't miss this extra special week one
bonus enter code h3h3 to get a free
shot at the one million dollar top prize
with your first deposit
that's called h3h3 only if draftkings
make it rain baby a minimum
of five dollar deposit is required lgbt
eligibility restricted apply
see drifley.com for details no i'm gonna
i'll read that seriously
minimum a five dollar deposit is
required eligibility
uh restrictions apply see draftking.com
for details
you know ela i saw one leaf on the
ground yesterday
you know what that means it's not summer
i hate summer summer's the worst
especially in la
but fall everybody loves fall and that
means that me
andy's got those hot fall halloween
spooktacular awesome undies
i still have the summer version after i
just hyped fall you're gonna show these
summer undies
they are gonna have some bomb mother
loving
halloween undies coming up though but
let me tell you about me undies more
importantly
you know there is a serious shortage of
quality
underwear in the world today you go
online what are you going to find all
this crap
hanes through the loom whatever to this
day i don't know where to buy underwear
yeah i mean i'm serious i've been
looking my whole life for good underwear
and then it's like
really cheap feeling it's coarse
sometimes i get this one with the
the waistband is super coarse and i get
like it just feels horrible
that's where meundies comes in they've
got this the softest fabric
the most breathable fabric these people
care about
comforting your dick and balls and your
vagina
is it important to the vagina to be in
good underwear or is it more like the
waist apparently
yeah i don't know i don't have one
it all matters it all matters take it
from a
her a girl you're right though it's more
about the way
i just don't know because my dick and
balls is very i need
i need space and but i i yeah sometimes
i buy underwear and the fabric just
feels so cheap and everything every time
yeah that's where me andy's come in it's
made from
sustainable natural fiber source from
sourced from beechwood called micro
modal
excuse me where did where was this made
in outer space
it's alien technology super soft it's a
breathable it's life
it's a light it's impossibly cozy and
it's seriously comfortable
everything me undies does is to help you
feel truly comfortable from head to toe
inside and out
[Music]
weird in honor of bobby lee okay but we
i don't know if we talked about
whatever never run don't ever run out of
undies
with the me undies membership a
subscription that sends new pairs right
to your door
plus get side site wide savings and
exclusive sales
keep your eyes peeled for their spooky
cool halloween prints
mandy's has a great offer for our
listeners for any first time purchase
you get 15 percent off and free
shipping it's a no-brainer especially
because they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means if you
don't love these undies as much as we've
guaranteed today
you send them back and then a dude will
sniff them
and but he'll give you your money back
no they won't sniff no sniffing do you
care if somebody sniffs your underwear
after you send it back i mean what do
you care not really yeah what do you
care
you don't see it they have a sniffer
it's his job he goes
yeah these were worn that is all made up
and they do not do that they don't have
a sniffer that i'm aware of
uh get 15 off your first order free
shipping and 1
billion percent satisfaction guarantee
at meundies.com h3 that's meundies.com
h3
so bobby you're yes ethan are you doing
hypnotherapy to quit smoking is that
right
well i did it and um what how many
secrets did i have yesterday
uh three i had three yesterday yeah
that's
one for a pack a day to three that's
really good that's pretty good i have
fears
of fear i just i i don't know like i
don't know
who this hypnotherapist is i don't know
look like intake of bobby's like
susceptible background
i've also seen the movie old boy and i
just don't
i just think that bobby's gonna freaking
have an octopus in his face
um one night when i come home and and
you know just do strange things around
so
so if i'm understanding you mistrust
this person tinkering around in his
brain yeah like i don't think that you
just meet someone one day
and without them knowing all the things
your triggers whatever he has a long
history of trauma
yeah and then just start [ __ ] around
and walk taking a walk in his head
i don't like he's a professional yeah
but he doesn't know you
we didn't we didn't go to we didn't go
to home depot and somebody just randomly
hey you want to hypnotize me
no we [ __ ] went to the best is he the
best
he's the king of all he looks like lex
luthor yeah when therapists are bald
right and he wears a scarf around his
neck that's [ __ ] legit
yeah right and he didn't do no [ __ ]
like ball or
a little thing to know he was not
old-school new school
new school hypno he got me in i went
onto a beach in my memory
so he got me all relaxed go to your
favorite place i went to my favorite
place right
and i and i went to a different you know
a world and i was completely relaxed
and and he was implanting little things
in my brain
and i think what we don't like
kala looks scared because she's like
what are we implanting
yeah what little seeds are we planting
in your head that we're now watering he
goes he
i was the probably like kill kalila yeah
yeah yeah exactly
bts army strong
yeah so you know i don't you know i've i
don't know
um a thousand hitting up to therapists
i've met maybe two in my life
yeah but from the from this guy compared
to the other guy he
looks seems legit that's true i think
that i'm basing it up because
i have i have an ex-friend who is a
hypnotherapist and a
reiki healer and i think that she's
absolutely right
wait what is reiki it's well i mean
i don't know if i'm going to offend
people but it sounds like [ __ ] well
what is it
it's like doing like oh this [ __ ] where
they don't touch you
they don't touch you right but it like
you're supposed to feel hit
just yeah it's it's it's for me it's
just
a little bit um quacky but you know do
you think
oh do you think the hypnotherapy is
quacky no no i don't think
i think the guy seems legit i was basing
it off my
friend who is a hypnotherapist and i
think that she is
so unqualified right right right right
sort of a disaster of a baby
baby baby you have you have hippie
desert friends they give you crystals
and then you take the crystals
and you put it to the on the side of the
bed no no that's not quacky
no no no i have my best friend is a free
diver
and she collects these things from the
bottom of the ocean
and she brings them back from mexico and
she gives them as a friend token
next to the bed like it's going to
illuminate like it's going to illuminate
and and
and it's just a cool it's like a cool
marine
cola do you believe that the crystal
infuses your being with
with some kind of energy i i i own zero
crystals there are zero crystals in the
shadows
in the whole house i saw crystals from
under water
the underwater crystals whether they're
from the land or underwater they're
still [ __ ] crystals
i
[Music]
let me ask some more questions here is
the hypnotherapist have credentials does
he have a degree of any kind
he is the master of all no no no that's
not what i asked
okay does he have a degree
okay listen i know i'm not bts okay yeah
so i don't have the
maybe there they could get like the
grand master of a hypnotherapist right
yeah
i can't get i i can get like above
average
professional professional hypnotherapist
i don't is he is he
is he a psychologist does he have a
background in this kind of [ __ ] or is he
just some dude who puts on a scarf and
he's like let's talk about yours
but you want to do it devry and that's a
very common
hypnotherapy no he um
i didn't ask that i didn't go where's
your credentials i think that the george
i think her producer found yeah where
did you find him
that doesn't sound that privileged
wait what's his foundation on craigslist
ask him to uh ask him to see if he has a
degree you can find online yeah
yeah does he have if you find a degree
and it better be harvard yeah
listen somebody i am curious though what
is it like what is the process of
getting
uh hypnotized is that what you're are
you being hypnotized
yeah so the process is this you know he
you close your eyes he and he said
you're on an escalator
are you laying down yeah no i'm in this
chair specific
specifically he came to your house no i
did it through zoom so i was in this
chair and i just hit him
right so um he told me to go to an
escalator i went up and then he goes
open up a door a golden door
they opened up the golden door and then
he goes now you're
wherever your favorite most relaxing
places mine was a beach
in in the philippines so i went on the
beach and then
all my friends were there and i laid in
the water
and then i kind of fell asleep and then
when he said to wake up i woke up
really yeah so there was like that's
really interesting there was a
five-minute
gap there where i don't really remember
what he did
really why that's so interesting yeah so
that i'd so
what if he was just sitting there in
silence
i'm the dum dum dum but
i don't think that's the truth it sounds
like it worked no no
no check it ethan ethan check it out so
when he says
now wake up i woke up so that means i
was listening the whole time yeah no i
agree
you got hypnotized bro i don't like so
weird to account for five minutes
yeah it seems very rapey yeah yeah like
would it
me too well well you can zoom right in
right well he kind of he kind of like
date raped you a little bit because you
black out
and then you wake up and you don't
remember what happened and he was like
it was all good and you just take it
it's funny that you say that because you
know when i woke up
my [ __ ] didn't hurt right all right
she's like now think of your [ __ ]
bobby
walk properly for a couple days but um
okay so excuse me so the point what's
wrong when you do that
i have gerd i have i have a gerd disease
gastro uh
yeah you've got bird [ __ ] i just started
um getting it really badly after the
whole bts fight
this is actually not even a lie on our
plane ride home from hawaii i just
i had to get the um like a barium x-ray
and everything like
it was it was it was up to here all the
time
yeah my throat is is super flemy it's
just i haven't i've had this problem for
a long time i take
medicine and stuff um so
is that the only way is that the only
thing wrong with you or no other
ailments no that's just the one that's
most apparent to you right now
you cut out there i said that's the only
one that's most apparent to you right
now
okay i have a lot of problems but do you
have do you take psychological meds i
take
uh antidepressants oh you do okay yeah
what about you
what about you bobby i take um a couple
things i take
um a beta blocker and i also take um
a high blood blood pressure medication
i'm loaded bean
i'm loaded and that one sleeping med
that helps you jerk off
oh he's quit he's quit since we last saw
you oh really
yeah i mean my my dick now is like wood
i mean it i mean there's no feet like a
a floating
what they're gone oh it's still there i
can see you
yeah they're still oh no yeah i can't
see you but um but there's really not a
lot of feeling in my dick
now you know because i don't take
medication oh that's so
i would think that your sensitivity
would increase from stopping it
no it's kind of like uh not numb but
like kind of like
it's not as because when you take you
know i used to take unisom
to masturbate and um we it the the
ejaculation was so powerful
yeah it was like you know when david
carradine tied his neck
to the door association okay and you
know when kung fu did that
so i don't know why kung fu would need
to do that but kung fu did that and he
did and then the lead singer of inexcess
did that too
yeah what an embarrassing way to die
it must be good it must be really good
though because but imagine the cops
showing up the cops showing up and
you're just
yeah imagine you're completely naked
yeah you have a like
you know i mean a rope tied your neck
against a doorknob or whatever
and your hand is on your penis and
you're just a corpse
no not really are you kink shaming a
dead guy
because because i will say that he was
probably in
absolute ecstasy on his way yeah his
face is like
did you guys did you guys ever make love
when bobby was on a unison
well yeah that was one of his
stipulations he wouldn't do it without
the units oh my goodness so how's your
love life now that
he's off that stuff well can i tell you
what you did the other day
let me see hold on which part not virgin
blake
no unfortunately the other one um the
other one yeah because
we've never said this before i want
[Music]
she has a crush she has a she has a
crush on somebody
a celebrity a celebrity not someone she
knows in person what's his first name
edgar ramirez ramirez all right so can
you pull up a picture ian
i want to see who or two were
fantasizing about
is it one of the bts guys
pull up taeyeon all right let's see who
we got here
oh interesting rug ed yeah yeah
white yeah no he's uh he's he's mexican
he's mexican oh he is yeah oh so
so i so we're she was um
i was still offended by that but you
know what are you gonna do i would just
i mean i would just accept the uh you
just gotta ride the hip
you gotta ride it you asked for it
so let me ask you this when you asked
were you kind of you were
it was almost like a bluff right or
she's like
you were scared that she was gonna go
crazy for for that guy edgar
no i was it was a curiosity right it was
like let's see if it's different
if i was edgar ramirez right but the
shock of the but the shock of
you know realizing that you didn't mean
that she would have blown
edgar ramirez so much better
than she normally does well it's just
some it's like a one-time
passion i think if she was [ __ ] edgar
ramirez for
you know however long you guys been
together you'd probably be getting the
he'd be getting a regular blow job as
well bobby
yeah imagine edgar ramirez saying like
imagine i'm bobby lee
right then you take the dick out or not
yeah i think it's just uh but who was
the other one you guys were mentioning
what was the other one yeah
we cannot talk about virgin play oh man
all right
you can't do me like that
well hey i'm fine with it it just hurts
so it's like i don't we don't want to
hear on the internet right when we talk
about people
don't like the fact that i'm with her
really
why yeah yeah yeah because people will
go she's only
with you i'd still read it every day on
comments yeah that's [ __ ]
you guys have been with you for your
money you know what i mean oh my god
you're ugly and she's pretty
so get you know hey wise up bro and
people will just say that and it's like
it hurts my feelings yeah so
pretty your feelings i mean like
completely just like
[ __ ] ev my entire life before knowing
you like [ __ ] everything or
whoever i was before him it's all i've
just been reduced
to that well let me just say that
um i can't believe are still yeah
sorry our dogs are going crazy hold on
i don't know why people can't accept
that bobby would have a
a beautiful loving uh girlfriend i mean
bobby
first of all you have a lot going for
you i mean thank you i really do
i'm not i'm not trying to i'm not trying
to be a nice guy
you're talented you're funny i mean sure
you have a tiny penis but
like people look past that
thank you i'm just kidding i don't know
how big your penis is
but for me it's especially weird because
you guys even have a podcast together
you can see your interactions yeah you
can see that it's a real relationship
with lots of complexity and you know the
real deal
i don't know what what is there to even
like but it was i
think people act as if she was the first
girl i've ever had
right i've been with right i've been
with a lot of attractive women some not
as attractive as her right but no but
super hot there's no i've never seen a
picture of his ex where i was like oh my
god so my point is
is that like that's the the game that
papa plays
right so does that cause trouble in your
guys relationship the people are always
questioning the nature of your guys's
love for each other no i think that
if if it were to ever cause
trouble it's mostly just me probably
feeling bad about it
in the beginning yeah then maybe like
trying to
figure out um how to yeah how to not
um absorb that kind of you know abuse
from the internet and stuff but if we
figured it out and
we don't talk about it so you know
why the question is why did i get into
stand-up what drove me right and at the
when i was 23 years old
i couldn't date any women because i was
so shy i looked the way i did right
i didn't really have great social skills
i had no confidence right
so i started doing stand-up and that
what that did it didn't change my
physical appearance right
but it changed the way i felt about
myself and that's i think
what you know got me to be with
women but the whole reason why i'm doing
the i think
at the end of the day um you know i do
entertainment because so that i can feel
more confident
and so that i can you know attract
people around me and just to live a
bigger life
so that has everything to do with it now
if i if i looked the way i did
i didn't have the confidence that i did
and i
didn't have a great job and i was had
low self-esteem
that i could understand in that
situation right
right yeah yeah and and you know it's
kind of
uh we have a very similar
we had a very similar upbringing like a
lot of um
when when bobby and i first met it was
like reuniting with an old friend
that feeling of like wait like you
understand me
completely and i don't know why or how
but it
felt immediately like there was
something there and we had so much to
talk about
and i just uh um i was immediately
attracted to
all of it in in the same in the same way
you know whatever he felt for me was way
way beyond
you know just like the physical nature
of it i mean and also like to be fair
i've always liked rotund guys
sorry that's always what guys i've
always liked
you know pear-shaped i've always liked
trouble
wait what was the first word of the word
oh okay i've never heard that
ila also likes wrote on men i don't know
road time
it sounds funny though yeah i mean when
you're
when you're making love to ethan do you
feel like what the [ __ ] am i doing with
this guy or no
yeah all every day no but i i
i like what you said because i feel like
people
just like they narrow down the whole
thing so much to like
just looks that it's so stupid like
you're
not just attracted to how a person looks
i don't know
i said well are you i no well especially
women
like what you do with your life is
attractive you know how you carry
yourself if you're
if you're creative in your life i'm find
that attractive you know it's
it's a lot of things and if i'm just
gonna date a beautiful guy
it can be a dum-dum and a shallow person
and i'm not gonna be attracted to him
your life's gonna suck yeah it's not
like it's not just
that like you're beautiful or not and
therefore you should date a beautiful
person or not
i think a lot of guys miss that that
first of all
really great a lot of really great women
out there
the looks and all that stuff is not the
number one thing they're looking for in
men
and i have like yeah i have 50 pounds of
fat on the table
as i'm talking yeah yeah me too
me too so um so yeah i think a lot of
guys have confidence issues because
they're like i'm not perfect i don't
have a perfect beautiful face and body
but
i mean you know that shouldn't slow you
down
and then i i'm attracted to what i'm
attracted to i'm sorry you know
i mean no did god make me
to go out with a four foot two
vietnamese girl named ting ting maybe
right but but i just you know i i found
her to be beautiful
right and then when we when i found out
about you know her
point of view about life and her heart
and how she is and how
she treats people that added that was
like everything
if guys tell me about virgin blake
we're getting away from the topic here
and i didn't forget i literally thought
that we were away
no no no oh you're a good one no
all right ah who's the ver is
blake okay so i had to ask my therapist
this beforehand because i was like look
like
does does the kink that we're into at
all represent who we are as people and
she was like absolutely not
you could be you could have like
murderous fantasies
in bed and that has nothing to do with
who you are
outside of sex so i was like okay cool
because
virgin blake he's of of age by the way
he just happens to be a virgin
when bobby becomes a virgin blake it
basically
takes like it takes me three
i mean because how long have you guys
been together again
like uh we got married in 2012 so eight
almost eight years
so we're at almost eight years
more like 13 years wow that's way long
baby
no do you guys um
i want a baby now yeah we talked about
it the last time we were on there
yeah but still we're still doing that
but um
how how has it been now with the baby
it's
good can you talk now can you talk now
he's starting to talk he's he's saying a
lot of words he's not talking but he's
saying a lot of words
but he understands a lot yeah he really
understands a lot
yeah he he like i'll say can you go show
that to dad and then he'll actually go
do it
like or i'll say spit it out this is
what i say to him a lot now spit it out
because he just picks it up off the
ground
dog food he loves eating dog food oh so
he goes spit it out and he goes
has your sleep been affected by it no
we're rich we have help
i mean just being honest with you but
it's because i just want to be honest
okay
it's hard for sure even with help yes
but i just need to be honest
like everybody who has
like some measure of success and money
they talk about having kids they all
have night nurses
yeah they have people well we don't have
at the beginning we don't have anything
it's but we have a nanny that comes in
the morning very early he's sleep
trained so
he sleeps through the night so we're
pretty lucky in that way
yeah he sleeps really good he almost
never wakes up in the middle of the
night
we don't have somebody here during that
time but but he he sleeps through the
night he's a he's a little champion
but um we both work so during the day we
have to have
help the first the first um six months
it was the
was the toughest it's really crazy the
first six months
but after that if they are sleep trained
if you get like a really good uh
uh how do you call it a nurse well what
do you call the baby
doula a doula to come and help you with
the night train
the night training and stuff then then
it's then it gets
it's not bad you know but what it really
was just the
the ultimate thing about it is just
having a schedule so
i never thought we could do it because
we don't have a schedule ourselves like
we're all over the place
all the time yeah with him we just have
to have a schedule so we're doing it and
like you immediately see how
good it is when you do it so that's why
we're keeping it like
you have to do everything at like in the
evening at the same way
dinner at 5 30 let's say and then bat
and then this and that and
he just follows it and he knows okay
we're going to sleep now
so oh so i can't sleep at like five in
the morning like i normally do
well you ca i mean we're trying to work
on that
i have the same problem yeah because i i
can't fall asleep before like
three and so i wake up really late but
the thing is that we have a nurse that
comes really early in the morning on the
weekends though we don't have a nurse
i prefer it that way because i want to
be forced to spend the time with them
and so i do feel like [ __ ] all the time
and my sleep cycle is super [ __ ] up
but but obviously no you don't want to i
mean you don't want to sleep till
you want to go to sleep at 5am when you
have a kid i mean you'll look like a
[ __ ] psycho
your kid's gonna think that's normal
behavior and that's a problem that i
have
because i'm really trying hard to adjust
my sleep schedule now because i don't
want theodore
to grow up what the expectations are
sleeping yeah exactly
but i think i'm depressed and i have all
kinds of issues that i'm trying to work
through right now so
see that's what i think kids gonna do
but but i'm afraid that it's not gonna
do what i think it's to do but what i
think it's going to do it's going to
curb some of my um the habits that i
have
you know like number one i think that
it's going to make me completely quit
smoking
number two it's going to make me not
play video games as much
number three it's gonna motivate me to
like do more in my career you know me
more proactive well i would i think it's
gonna
yeah go ahead sorry to cut you off i
thought you were done
i am done i am [ __ ] done
it's hard on these zoom calls uh yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't
i would have a i wouldn't expect the kid
to change
bad habits you know what i mean you kind
of have to like
be in a good place then have the kid
because i feel like beat me to it i i
feel like the kid can even exhaus
exacerbate bad habits because it's so
stressful so hard
at the beginning and and you have to be
at your best
to handle it because it is so hard
but at the same time i i see your point
it may help in some sense
yeah yeah yeah you do have to follow his
schedule you do have to be consistent
there
for him and it's going to be the most
important thing for you so you're going
to have to do that you know
yeah i i i know this about myself
i know once i see the baby there's just
no way for me not to be affected by it
yeah i know that i'm gonna have a cosmic
experience from it
yeah that i know for sure yeah right so
i just know that i'm gonna look at this
baby
and because i you know the reason why i
i can stay sober for big chunks of time
is because of the fact that like you
know at the end of the day
it's based on i want to be present for
my mom my brother and kalylah
right so i just know that extreme things
like that do
change me mm-hmm right so i i beg to
differ
but they have a really different like
it's basically like
if you're if if you want
you're about to go into a situation like
they said is like
super different and on top of that super
stressful and
all those escapist habits that you
already have to get
out of difficult situations right aren't
going to disappear when a difficult
situation presents itself
you might even there's a possibility
like ela said that it could be
exacerbated
if if the baby's crying i'm not going to
go i'm going to go play warzone for five
minutes
yeah i'm not gonna do that either
because i'm going to look at the baby
and go i want i want
i want to be alive for the baby i want
i want to experience and i want to be
there i think bobby would make i think
bob would be a great person a
great parent i think you should have
kids i'm not saying look i know we said
that last time to you guys and yeah i
think that you guys would be
great parents i don't want to give the
wrong impression i think you guys are in
a great spot
i think you guys are in a loving
relationship you guys are in a great
financial situation
you still have nine months to work on
yourself yeah the
clock starts the clock does start no i
think you'd be a great dad bobby
and uh and even if you're not a perfect
dad that kid is still gonna be happy and
in a good home
and you're not gonna be a perfect dad
nobody is a perfect parent there's no
such thing
but you know i'm not going to do what my
dad did my dad would beat me
yeah right yeah my dad beat my mom right
i want to correct some of that thing
yeah you're going to be a great dad
all right thank you going to be a great
guy we can move on but i don't like the
accusations
no i didn't i didn't mean to calm down
on you it sounded like that
yeah you'd be a great dad thank you
that's all i wanted to hear yeah
yeah yeah why don't you just say i'm
going to be a great dad and let's move
on
but just so you know we're still trying
to work on it ethan still stays up too
late we're still we're working on it
though it might take time it's like a
big adjustment
we've never i think we're doing a good
job though yeah
yeah he's happy he's very happy yeah
he's a great guy
what do you guys fight about like in
this pandemic what is the thing that
like you guys fight about
um um sometimes uh
well we used to fight about food a lot
but not so much anymore
we don't fight that much honestly to be
honest ila got mad
eva gets mad at me sometimes when i
tweet stuff that's that's the one thing
that i can think of
she doesn't like sometimes i'll make
tweets she doesn't like and then she'll
get mad at me like a political tweet or
something yeah
is the same way okay with the political
ones actually it's more the drama ones
yeah she doesn't she gets mad when i
tweet stuff
do you respond to because you know i
every once in a while i'll like i'll
break down and i'll respond to a
negative comment or a tw
or or a direct message or something like
somebody will say something like um
you know hey dude stop doing podcasting
you're bad at it
and and you know sometimes i can look at
something like that and go let it go let
it go let it go let it go right
but every once in a while go oh is that
why so
this many people listen you [ __ ] you
know like i'll go crazy right
do you respond to stuff like that well
well i just
no but those comments do make me sad and
so i just don't read comments for the
most part
ah that i should do that but generally
no i wouldn't respond to it because
i just feel i just feel bad and then
move on
yeah i used to yeah i used to i just
know that um
it's not going to accomplish anything
and that person's just going to get
attention that they want
and there's not you can't you can't on
you can't never convince these people
that you're good enough you know what i
mean
right yeah they're gonna hate you no
matter what you say and do forever right
yeah but mike my question though is why
you know
okay there are things there are people
and music musical bands and things that
i don't like
right there are actors that i just find
not that kind of annoying me
right but and they seem to all work and
all that stuff
and i'm not going to name who those
people i don't hurt their feelings but
in no why would i go out of my way to
say
hey man just let you know you suck like
i would never do that no i wouldn't
naughty
everybody why do people do that i'm
really not sure
i think because they're honestly i would
never do that
i don't think i know anyone that would
do that the only way that i can imagine
is that they're very
uh hurt they're very bitter and jealous
and mad that their life sucks i mean
that's really the only explanation
but it doesn't make it hurt any less no
yeah yeah
yeah no but but it's true i mean nobody
else would leave that comment unless
they were just bitterly
unhappy with their life yeah yeah it's
not personal is what you're saying i
don't know it's never
it's not personal and they're only
saying it because they're like my life
[ __ ] sucks
and your life rules so you wouldn't they
think that you would never in a million
years be offended or care about what
they say
yeah because they see you as some
invincible person
you know what i mean yeah you know it's
it's funny because
um and this is the honest truth and it's
not really that humorous
but you know i've been kind of thinking
to myself
do i feel the same about myself and the
same way about life that that i that i
did felt
30 years ago and i feel the same way
like you know it's like you know yeah
i've had these last five years i've had
some success
and this has been an incredible pandemic
for me i'm getting a lot of work for
some reason you know
i assume the worst i thought like oh for
the next whenever
until they have vaccine i'm not going to
work or nothing's going to be happening
but
you know i'm still getting calls you
know you know
i sold a show you know congratulations
on uh
to abc so i'm very awesome excited about
that and there's like a lot of other
good things happening in my life
but at the end of the day it's like i
still feel like the piece of [ __ ] that i
did
30 years ago right so i just don't think
that it's weird like i don't
feel different or you know about myself
or
you know what do you say 30 years ago
how how do you mean like in
like does success affect happiness that
kind of
no because i i just feel like you know
people go people
tweet at me or they say negative things
like look at this guy this guy you know
shouldn't be killing it or sh you know i
mean or why can't i be
you know but i just want to tell these
people that listen i still feel like a
piece of [ __ ]
yeah we all you know that's the thing
yeah yeah i i don't feel
different than you i'm not a god i'm
like you cannot harm me
mortals yeah yeah i don't that hurts my
feelings
yeah yeah yeah i get i'm as sensitive
you uh i have
you know depressive depressing days yeah
you know i'm self-conscious you know
there's all these things that
never really went away you know i'm the
same guy
right but then people like attack me
like i'm as if i'm supposed to be
here when i'm always i've always been
here
you know it's just an odd psychological
thing that i have to
do yeah i think i i think i've i've been
through that
that cycle too honestly the only
solution i've ever found that's had any
success for me is just you have to
really just not engage or read
in the comments because you know what it
is it's like people
talking about you and you eavesdropping
on a conversation about you
it's like a conversation you're not
meant to be a part of or to know
even what people are saying in the real
world let's say you go to high school
and there's 5 000 people at your high
school you're not supposed to know what
every single person in that high school
says about you in every conversation
right
you go crazy and also what they would
say behind your back
they want to say to your face and they
may not even mean let's be honest
right that's what i mean like sometimes
you can be really mean when you're just
talking like to someone else but you
don't mean you talk to that person you
would never say that to their face you
ever done that where you talk [ __ ] about
someone and then afterwards you're like
i don't mean that at all
i like that person yeah you know what i
mean
yeah i do it all the time that's a
really good way to frame that good way
to frame it
so you have like i've even said things
like you know i to somebody just to
if somebody says i like this movie and
i'll go that movie sucks
but i've seen the movie 50 times
the director of that movie you'd
probably be like dude big fan yeah
oh yeah all right love that movie
well i've also said good things about
people but i don't even mean it
oh no that's not good no but i
i'm a big fan and i go i hate that guy
okay but
but so like the point is right yeah the
point is
i don't want to name the person but i
remember being on the paramount lot
and i saw oh my god here's this jackass
you know i [ __ ] hate this guy right
and i went i'm a big fan i think i had
to do tears in my eyes
you know what he said he goes he goes um
thanks and he just kind of like did and
then i went oh i hit it even more
so but the point is that these are not
these aren't really real reflections of
people's hearts and souls
and so the only you can't really live
your life sanely
and reading all this [ __ ] about yourself
you just have to put out your thing
uh i do find that when i don't look at
anything i am happier
it's just that simple because just don't
look at anything and i'm
walking around in my daily and i'm
happier yeah you don't care and when i
do stop and look at this [ __ ] it makes
me feel bad
every time because look all you can do
is you put you do your thing
you have the people in your immediate
life in that room with you now
you let's say you do an episode of
podcast you're like that was good i felt
good that was a fun episode so you put
it out and you leave with that feeling
or you say you say that podcast uh we
could have improved on these things
but you know it's not that serious you
just like mental note we can improve on
that you walk out you live your life
you know if you go to the comments it
will ruin your [ __ ] day and by the
way it will pollute
the actual productive thoughts you had
about it in either case right
you're like i'm going on my day and have
a good day they're like not
[ __ ] you your day's real even have a
podcast
yeah yeah wait that's the thoughts
you're gonna end up with
yeah let's say you have a bad podcast
and then of course everybody's just
talking about this one awkward moment
they're gonna amplify it and make it a
million times worse
you know already in your mind that oh
that's something i can work on and prove
but they're going to ruin your whole
[ __ ] year so you
like how much better off would you be
not even knowing that conversation's
happening
you're right you're right you're right
you're right that's going to stop doing
that like sometimes i fish for it and
it's not yeah of course
yeah we all do yeah now let me ask you
guys what do you guys do because
i want to comment on political things
but i don't i don't i do i'm not
i'm not going to tell people what i am
politically right now i don't want to
get into it but
but like but when i'm on i literally
will read something
and i'll go out of my mind i can't
[ __ ] believe it i feel like
we used to be like that we used to try
to stay out of politics and i'm
i just grew tired of that it felt like
genuine we're not fully expressing
ourselves and i'd rather
i enjoy listening to people i like talk
about politics
and then i figured why wouldn't we just
talk about what we
are thinking right now you know so first
of all it's not for everyone and i'll
warn you
if you do there's so many people online
especially that will [ __ ]
hate your guts for it that's why we
stopped doing it that's why we stopped
doing it
yeah this guy is also as utter hate but
it is really coming from a political
place sometimes you know what's that
once i got uh i'm not even really
political but let's say once i started
being more outspoken with my political
thoughts
there was like a huge [ __ ] concerted
effort from like right lane right
influencing things
and it comes in all kinds of word first
of all you get people who are just mad
at you in the comments
and but but yeah you're gonna get [ __ ]
for it but
in my case i i feel like
my whole schtick has always been calling
out [ __ ] where i see it
and so one of my for me it felt
hypocritical to just
look away and not be true to myself in
that regard
right so like yeah it's risky and
it's gonna it can cause you a lot of
[ __ ] and it's true what people say you
know it's everywhere
people say that it's everywhere why do i
need to see it here whatever
i think that the reason we um i i
at least hesitate or i tell you let's
not speak on something is because
we're not as versed as you guys we don't
find ourselves
i'm not bright enough i'm not bright
enough to defend my position
me too that's the problem i'm not either
not either
yeah no i know exactly what you mean and
so there are certain times when i get
into it and i'm like
i'm honestly i don't i don't know what
i'm talking about
but here's a is it possible that nobody
knows what they're talking about
yeah very impossible so people are just
better at sounding
because who can even figure out what the
[ __ ] is going on in this world i mean
what is really happening you know yeah i
can just tell from my
personal perspective as a listener to
other people
when there's a person i like and then
they talk about politics
i like listening to them talk about it
because i like this person and i
and they usually say it the way i'm
thinking you know they usually
express what i'm thinking and i'm so
frustrated about something and they'll
say it and it's
fun to listen to but so yeah there are
certain things you could talk about that
don't
require you having an intimate knowledge
of policy for example
uh eric what's his name eric
is that is that his unloved son yes eric
trump yes
trump the biggest so he tweeted out this
morning and i quote tweeted him he says
here pull it up can you pull it up ian
you guys got to see this it's the
dumbest [ __ ] thing i've ever seen
and i'm like okay and i'm just like why
are we putting this guy up on
a pedestal he's a [ __ ] he is literally a
[ __ ] brain dead imbecile pull this up
i mean like people are really putting
this guy on a pedestal um
so he goes google is once again trying
to manipulate americans
type mob or mobs into google and watch
what comes up
do the same on any other search engine
and what showed up is this anime mob
cycle 100 the character's name is mob
and he thinks this is some incredible
conspiracy theory
to keep people from seeing what a mob is
on google images
because he doesn't know what a what this
anime is
i mean i mean this is a great one by the
way
so like i'm not i don't need to make
some great political
statement and just to know that he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
right and so i just i wish you didn't
show me that
yeah that that i mean i wish you didn't
show me that yeah
and so i just quote tweeted and said
imagine being this dumb
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah i think that
you know i um i think i'm gonna start
doing it a little bit more
i have moments of being fired up but i
don't try to
i try to sort of um argue amongst like
my own circle of people that i know
because i feel like that's that's if i'm
gonna have any impact it's probably
going to be
in that small little microphone that's
smart
and it's true and then work my way out
because like especially in the filipino
community we have a lot of
um we have a lot of issues with race uh
with the colonial mentality
um with a lot of self-loathing that
reflects on who we choose as our leader
so i try to get into like those smaller
discussions
and it's yeah even in those small
discussions it's really
it gets really ugly very fast yeah it's
like when
it's like when the [ __ ] [ __ ] face
leader of the free world right
says kung flu or the china virus
right which is saying a lot now and
people don't realize that it affects
people that look like me living in this
country yeah
i don't understand why they don't see
the connection that
you know p the mob right or
a group of people are gonna view me as
if i'm some sort of
some implication that i had something to
do with the virus and i'm gonna you know
and now you most likely have the virus
like
right right and asians are now getting
like you know hit in the face on the
middle of the street you know and and
he did people don't realize that
connection but and i'm so afraid
to even talk about it right because i
don't want to get attacked by these
people
right so it's like a weird [ __ ] thing
so you know what
i want to start saying things you know
right because that that is hurtful when
he says [ __ ] like that
yeah but you know like what ethan says
just say it and then feel good about it
yeah let it live and feel good that you
said it think about it before you put it
out
make sure it's what you want to say yeah
and then just let it live and be happy
and let me
let me spell check it because you have
yeah you want to make sure it's all
spelled
i really it's i've been with him for
seven years
right and the cutoff
spell how dare you what oh that
literally everyone was like what you
should at least be self-aware
i guess i used to be better i mean i've
known worse i've known worse spellers
yeah yeah i'll make him take whole posts
down
because of kudos dan just screamed at me
like damn apparently i got a spelling
issue
it's just just the other day you had you
had a pretty bad one on a tweet and so
wait what did i misspell in a tweet oh
geez oh because
first of all everybody
in the group chat spell checked it and
nobody corrected me
[Laughter]
i literally showed the tweet to
everybody in our whatsapp on the podcast
and nobody
corrected it and i'm the bad speller i
was busy or something he was busy
anyway but but bobby i think you you tap
into a good point it's like
i uh it's like um they they
this is what they want right they they
they rule by this
this this fear and and they make it
like uh you can't speak up for your own
well-being
i mean yeah we have a president that's
perpetuating racial
stereo harm very hurtful harmful racial
stereotypes
against you yeah and so why the [ __ ]
shouldn't you speak up
yeah and i feel and i should because i
have a voice
and i should for the the millions of
[ __ ] asians
out there that need a voice you know and
i'm being a coward because you know
i just don't want to [ __ ] get
involved but i have these deep feelings
about it right of rage you know yeah and
i just don't get
why people don't understand that that
what he's saying is
divisive and that it's causing because
they like that
dude because those these are the times
we're living in it's sad and it's it's
upsetting
because the people who like and love
donald trump like that it's defensive
and harmful
because they don't look like you and
they think it's [ __ ] they think it's
great that it's triggering people
because you know i saw him at a rally
and he goes
you know uh the wuhan flew
and then he was like kung fu the kung
flu and he's like the kong flew and
everyone's like yeah
i mean [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah and it's it
and you when you watch you go
you what's amazing is he
has shown us the amount of people that
back that kind of ideology
isn't that shocking when you see polls
when you see polls you go
what that many people
it's so just eye-opening right that's
you know you're talking about 45 percent
yeah in the polls right and you and
that's if you look at that
i mean that means that when you're in
the midwest you have to kind of look
around
half these people and you know that
we've
forever changed just in the last four
years too and
um proof of that is four years ago
the most profound and earth-shattering
thing we watched was
um going clear the the documentary about
scientology
yeah yeah and then two days ago we saw
it we
watched it because we wanted our niece
to watch it and it was the most boring
thing we've
ever done
yeah yeah we have been like you know
we're
so jaded now but you know what but even
beyond like the
um even beyond
fighting the hate and and propaganda and
racism
i just think that they're really ripe
for satire because it's a bunch of
[ __ ] white trash bozos
and a bunch of girls whoa ethan whoa
you're right but you're right but whoa i
think it's a no but it's so
ripe for commentary these people there's
so much comedy to make out of this
stupidity
that donald trump donald trump
is a such an oaf and his family it's
such [ __ ] bimbos it's a family of
bimbos
yeah and everyone surrounding him and
all these pundits and everybody i mean
there's just
there there are a bunch of [ __ ]
hateful morons tucker carlson looks like
like he's perpetually lost and confused
i love his bow ties though he's cute
but but i'm just saying i'm gonna eat
some oatmeal
yeah but you know what enrages me more
okay so i saw on the internet right
some you know a white older white
conservative guy
he was a chad right and he's berating
some
you know black people about something
right and next to him
was an old his wife who was an old
asian lady and she's like yeah you all
right you know she's like defending you
know
her husband right those those asians
right that you hang out with they drive
me yes [ __ ] crazy that's what keeps
them up at night yeah i
hate you know what like mitch mcconnell
mcconnell's wife what's her name
um i forget remember like one time trump
had a press conference
and here's this like concubine that's
why i said concubine
they're [ __ ] concubines all right
they bind their feet they walk on their
back and they they go
and they do that all the whole thing it
[ __ ] drives me crazy you think she's
like
a race trader yeah there's a betrayal
there
you know i i feel that i just i you know
yeah there's a lot of that too in the
filipino community yeah
and there's so much it really that's
that's the one thing that i see it's
like
but it also comes from a colonial
mentality thinking that um
you have a seat at their table because
you've kind of been
um yeah you it it it warps the way you
you you view yourself and then you sort
of praise your abuser
so that's that's very for filipinos it's
a lot
it's very much because we've been um
colonized by our whole history of our
country right
yeah it's like when you go to thailand
i've been to thailand right and uh you
know i shot a movie there once where i
was out there for months and i would
walk down the street and i would see
a 70 year old american white man
holding hands with like an 18 year old
right asian girl right and they're just
walking down the street all confident
with their with you know with basically
you know it's like it's pedophilia
that's what it is
right and you see that and i don't know
what it is about that
but it drives me [ __ ] crazy and for
some reason i equate you know
you know a certain section of trump
supporters like that
you know i don't know there's a
connection there for me right
of like users or you know
i will say though not to over generalize
because
first of all i know what you mean but i
do think that like
there's a large section of trump
supporters that are racist
just shitty divisive trolls whatever but
a lot of the people are just like
think they they just think
he's an honest politician that he's
different and he says it like it is
and he doesn't mean all that stuff he
says or maybe they don't even pay
attention and they don't understand
you're right
they're good they are good people but
they don't they don't understand
and it's hard to understand because
let's say that they're watching fox news
and according to fox news
everything's [ __ ] great you know i
try to soften my feelings for like old
white politicians by trying to imagine
them
in their little sleepy hat before they
go to bed at night
like and i think about their old you
know how like old man smell
yeah like because my dad was an old guy
and i just imagine like oh they probably
have that old
man smell and they probably have the
liver spots like all over and they
probably wear their little sleepy hat
before
even trump even biden so i think okay
like maybe they're not as evil
yeah they're not i don't think i think
there's very few people in this world
that are actually evil
but but what can you do because
i think there are some evil people that
like
like i don't know it's kind of evil to
run a uh ad on facebook that says
like hillary clinton rapes kids or
something knowing that that's not true
yeah i don't know do you ever google the
top 10 most evil people
that ever lived on the planet no google
that who ranks them i don't know that
like on rancor makes that list it's very
interesting
made by god i have no idea god made this
list
yeah hey ian can you pull up top 10 most
evil people
i think i i mean you guys before you do
that before that let's get let's try to
guess
okay hitler number one try to guess all
right so no
no let's just say so i think stalin
should be is it in there
okay here's an interesting one vlad the
impaler
wait you know what i have a feeling he's
already looked at this because i have a
vague memory of him recycling i already
know
what about gangnam style no he's not
maybe maybe he's top 20 but that was
pretty brutal he's not a top
genghis khan is like people who like
sonic youth like there's a cult
he's like
yeah i love that band uh daydream nation
is a great album but my point is is that
i think um what's that guy's name uh his
name is
hitler yes yes thank you for bringing
him up
yeah yeah so adolf hitler's on it um
paul pogba we said he's asian so vlad
the impaler is a little bit more obscure
and that's how i know you probably look
at this list yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i'm thinking who else
we got i mean i think some of the
imperialists who came to america and cut
all the natives like
uh who's the spanish dude who like gave
all the natives smallpox and killed like
like half a million to america what was
his name
chris i'm not sure no was it wasn't
columbus who gave them smallpox was it
uh it was a spanish dude intentionally
yeah uh
i mean who went to mech like uh cortez
osama bin laden we should be on the list
magellan
magellan okay pull it up and pull it up
pull it up pull it up yeah here we go
you guys want me to do a top 10 voice
coming in
here are the 15 most evil people to have
ever been born
okay coming in at number one adolf
hitler
adolf hitler killed nine million people
six million jews he did not like jews
people
all right number one coming in at number
two
joseph stalin i said stalin
he killed a hell of of his own people
because
oh vladimir's number three bro
one for bobby point for bobby why did
you even think to say that i kind of
agree that you must have cheated on this
test
who even knows who vlad the impaler is i
do
uh pol pot there we go himmler
oh another not say that the nazis are
topping the list
saddam
i mean he's i think he's black
oh okay yeah yeah can you expand
there's gotta be diversity here you
gotta have put a black eye in there wait
hey i don't see
there needs to be diversity here we're
getting some photos
there we go okay white dude saddam
yeah he could be mexican right there oh
yeah
let's see let's read about him he was in
uganda
he promised to bring prosperity but a
week later he did call himself president
as dictator became known as the butcher
of uganda killed people by feeding them
to crocodiles
like he was also a cannibal and
mutilated one of his wives
and re-arranged her limbs
he killed and tortured around half a
million people so congratulations to
edie
amin for making it to number seven
better try next better luck next time
yeah yeah
okay i haven't terrible ivan the
terrible yeah he looks terrible he does
he looks mean yeah you wanna that's cool
that's a cool look
keep going ian people don't keep going
[Music]
yeah see i don't even know these people
are too low on the list but keem
kim kim sung the second i mean who are
we talking about
wait they put all of them in the same
list kim kim
song kim jong-il
it sucks because they're probably like
two of them are in heaven going we tied
they're upset you know man we don't get
our own category
yeah that's true that's kind of a dis
nero man this
uh yeah oh this guy doesn't have a photo
that's how old he is
genghis god made it there he is
that's me that's my [ __ ] headshot
hang on let me make this dude look just
like me
here you probably are related i mean he
raped that many people my god
his bloodthirsty nature led to many
victories such as
many parts of china but also the killing
of countless people it is believed that
his men
if out of water would drink blood from
their horses his arms killed 15 million
people
uh a total of 20 to 60 million people
died during his reign god bless him
number 13. now
a lot of asians a lot of asians on the
list that's interesting yeah yeah it's
interesting
who's this idiot who's this guy wait
what who's this freak
he looks like the evil maximilian
look at that oh this is the arena terra
guy yeah
he only killed a hundred thousand loser
i i lose her
coming in at the bottom of the list at
number 15
maximilian robosphere with a hundred
thousand
people murdered rose pierre robespierre
thank you zach
wow no women oh no women no women
what about those that's interesting i
feel like they
if they had the agency back then they
would there'd be some on the list
yeah oh that's true no gays
how would you know that i don't know how
would you know that
bobby yeah okay well i can do it
genghis khan for sure he didn't bend
dudes over and like
[Laughter]
historically in china homosexuality was
actually so
okay and a long time ago in china and it
was not
it so yeah it would make sense that
genghis khan
all right well it's okay i feel like
genghis khan [ __ ] at least one dude in
his life
yeah just to try it sure because dracula
is
is based on vlad the impaler but the
impaler he has to have fun so he has
the funny exactly yeah so he seems gay
yeah yeah yeah you are good you who is
gay
why are you gay can you guys hear that
yeah what is that it's a sound bite
there's this guy uh it's really funny
video of
some african guy who's really he's
really
sweet and genuine he just doesn't
understand the concept of homosexuality
or
or trans so there's this trans person
who comes on and he goes
why are you gay
and and then she goes well i'm trans i'm
not gay and he goes
so who is gay
is he asian is it another african oh i
african i see
who is good you know what i've never
googled the nicest people
that's ever lived oh we can do that
[Applause]
that's easy i feel like i mean all i can
think of is
yeah who else is nice oh mr rogers who
else is nice for some nicest people
elmo mother teresa um
elmo yeah elmo wasn't mother teresa
secretly a douche
or was that someone else i think that
gandhi was secretly
kind of a pedo wait wasn't mother teresa
like letting people die and [ __ ] and
like it came out that she was like
actually a horrible person
oh she would have been canceled by now i
think yeah oh gandhi was [ __ ] kids i
don't think
i think that what i read was he would um
test his willpower by laying next to
his like 14 year old nieces but he
didn't [ __ ] him
i'm not sure the extent he's like i
failed guys
it's you know one time you know i used
to think that deepak chopra was like
a god i did i did
and then one time one time my buddy goes
yeah deepak chopra and his family ate at
my restaurant
i go uh-huh and he goes they only left a
five percent tip
and as soon as i heard that shout out i
shattered it
wow yeah i burned all his books seven
spiritual losses
i burned all that i mean dude if you're
deepak you gotta
what are you doing walking around you
gotta [ __ ] put down twenty percent
i have a question to you guys then oh
yeah so let's say someone were to
pay for dinner do you look at how much
they're tipping just so
the um the
they whoever doesn't think that you you
guys are cheap
i well first of all i usually just
go out with my family and i always pay
we've been in situations where we were
with friends
and then yeah we would look at the tips
sometimes they leave a really bad tip
and i'm like dude you can't
yeah yeah because then the wait staff
will think that you guys well you know i
have famous friends who
or they go ten percent where i max out
they like make a whole point about it oh
no
and actually you know what we've even
been banned from restaurants because of
it
i swear to god we stopped going to a
specific restaurant
because my our one friend tipped so
badly
that we got we he got beef with one of
the waiters
no really i swear to god wow and it was
our favorite restaurant too and then
we're like we can't go there anymore
i used to eat with a rich when i was
poor
i kind of want to say her name because
she died a [ __ ] i'll say it well well
she's dead you don't have to it's not
important to the story what's her name
bobby
oh no i'm not going to say but she was a
powerful rich old lady
all right it's everyone twice not every
once well only twice she took me to
dinner
right and she left she leaves no tip
and she's american she's not european
american yeah yeah so the first time i
ate with her she
so the second time i ate with her i knew
that she was gonna give a tip
so i had money
that i put into a little ball
like crunch it up in a ball right and so
when we got up from the table i just
threw it on the table you didn't want
her to see it i knew that she wasn't
she didn't see it no you don't want to
offend her like yeah what are you doing
because you're so [ __ ] cheap you know
i don't want to say get into that
conversation
right yeah so i just wanted to just put
it give it give it to the waiter
yeah i hate it i because i [ __ ]
i used to wait tables me too yeah yeah
we all the it's the worst feeling yeah
when you
work your [ __ ] ass off and they leave
you
no [ __ ] tip or or they leave little
yeah
it's it i used to like lose sleep over
that [ __ ]
because they don't realize how you know
you know how you have you you come to
work and they go hey sally didn't show
up
you have to take on her tables too so
you have [ __ ] 10 tables
you're running around you have ketchup
mustard you don't mean you have like
the fork you know what i mean somebody
had a dirty you have to memorize
all these issues and you're just
constantly running running
running running running running running
right and then you [ __ ] end of the
shift
you know you have no money i gotta tell
you right waiting money
one of the hardest most exhausting jobs
i've ever had
yeah you're moving like a
so fast and then like mistakes happen
obviously because you're moving so fast
and furious and then it's just horrible
people are so crazy when yeah i feel
like my whole memory of it is just like
the worst in people
like it just brings the worst in people
yeah the customers hate you the kitchen
hates you
the bar hates you everyone hates you i
just
it's all negative for me yeah i don't
know why people go
this system is [ __ ] up i'm not leaving
a tip i think only rich people say that
and then they go
but it's like dude this waiter is not
getting rich off your [ __ ] tip
yeah yeah yeah yeah five dollars dude
they need it yeah
we tip double when um when the service
is horrible
because we assume that they're having a
bad day wow no that's not that's not
what i do
we hang out with that guy he like
splashed the soup into her face like
this guy threw it as a frisbee yeah like
a hug
and he just threw it like a frisbee and
it splattered yeah yeah so that's how i
do it i do got a double tip
he did when i get really shitty service
and i like the food and i like the
restaurant
i leave double so the next time i go in
there and if i so happen to have the
same waiter
he knows right that i'm a good tipper
that he treats me differently well maybe
he thought
his behavior his initial behavior was
what got him the double tip so he's
going to keep pouring soup in your
throat yeah
you're into that that's your king it's
your kink
he's like oh this guy have to be mean to
blake over here
[Laughter]
you know you know what my brother you
know what my brother and i like to do is
we
we went to a wendy's once and dinen
what you dined in no we no because we
wanted to get their
cone okay right of ice cream is it
embarrassing to dine in that wendy's
you're right
yeah super embarrassing i've done so my
brother it was in korean town so my
brother and i went and
and the lady was so rude when we asked
because she i guess the machine was like
not on or whatever
so she gave an attitude like right and
so
i didn't like her attitude so when she
gave me the thing
i threw it in the trash and i ordered it
again
well how did she respond he was even
more furious
than but my brother and i were laughing
so hard
oh my god my brother thought that i was
going to keep ordering it
because we would repay for it right yeah
it's all good
yeah i hate that service yeah it drives
me crazy
oh my god what's the biggest [ __ ] up you
had as a waiter
oh my god i had so many i i got
a lot of complaints because my thumb was
in the food really
ah that's the best because
because i have little hands right yeah i
have little hands so
some of the the plates are big right
yeah so i can't
so i had to do it by the edges and my
thumb would be in the food
whatever that means so many people saw
your thumb in the food and then didn't
say anything or just like
i gotta eat it but this dude's in the
food
but it's also like it was a breakfast
place so my thumb would be in an
omelette oh no dude right so it would
puncture the almond the cheese would be
on my
you're dripping over my thumb right so
yeah
right you know we're really spineless
about things like that like if that were
to happen to us
if there was a hair in our food or food
was [ __ ]
we're spineless we don't we don't say a
word we just nod and say it's delicious
it's great receiving the food pretend to
eat it
and then just go absolutely i think most
people do that's what i'm saying
how many people but i'll be like i'll be
like with you like this is the this is
[ __ ] awful i hate it this is the
worst food
how's your food it's great that's what
that's what we do
that's what we are it's great yeah thank
you so much there was a place called
oscars and i ordered bread sticks
and i swear to [ __ ] in the middle of
the bread stick there was
a [ __ ] nail a human oh like a
like a fingernail no not a fingernail a
hammer
not a fingernail a [ __ ] nail
and so i ate the bread stick and i just
left the nail oh my god
but i didn't complain i ate ate the
whole [ __ ] hey just so you guys
yeah there was a nail in my red stick
yeah
the experience here is better i think
americans are more
polite yeah and israel don't give a [ __ ]
which i kind of learned from you
and i like that i think that's great but
i think in israel people are very
confrontational i dare you to try to
return a meal in israel
that'd be like the [ __ ] yeah can i tell
you story
i got but i was ordering food during my
lunch break in israel
this is the kind of [ __ ] you can expect
to see woman's on the phone
i'm getting a to-go box you know it's
like a box it's got different containers
and then she picks up the to-go box and
she puts her
[ __ ] cell phone in the to-go box to
rest there
[Laughter]
she goes can i help you and her phone
that she was just
on she is in the box she's about to put
food in
yeah yeah what did you do i was a [ __ ]
and i took the food and i ate it
all right because i was just too
embarrassed i was like wait
the phone was in the food no no before
before the food was scooped
up i couldn't believe what i was saying
and i
i still took it because i was in israel
i think israel is a little behind
on like hygiene in general being like
yeah yeah oh yeah another example
dude's making shawarma whatever he's got
gloves on right
and then you're paying with dollar bills
and he's handling the money
with the gloves and then touching your
food it's like what do you
yeah the gloves to protect his hands not
me yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so weird
just like did you say anything
no of course not yeah me either i would
like yeah i
don't i i'm very like i i i zone in
on those behaviors in america but if it
were to happen in a different country
for some reason like i allow it
yeah like i only because yeah it's kind
of like common
it will be everywhere once you start
pointing it out it will be your day
like you just have to point it out
everywhere
yeah i tried it once when i ordered like
a
sabi it's like a falafel kind of in pita
and they the guy wasn't wearing gloves
and i was like
that was like after i've been kind of
americanized by ethan
and i was like can you wear gloves oh my
god thought you were crazy right
a little bit he's like [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] he was like what the [ __ ] that's
crazy
yeah yeah of course and then he went
gloves but then he handled money with
the gloves
exactly
dude let me tell you israel is a shock
to me when i first went there you go to
the grocery store
okay the floor is [ __ ] coated
in dirt yeah it's not shiny like here
like dirt so beautiful and then
they have like the bread rolls and [ __ ]
people just
bare-handed throw it back in
yeah yeah olives yeah pickles
huge buckets yeah just
i mean it's a whole different world dude
yeah i think that there is
one stark difference between like
at least asian countries or foreign
americans are not good
um post poop wipers also the gr
i've seen i've never seen so many women
wipe
back to front like i have in america the
front oh women
oh really i never known it back to front
wipers
they they take the toilet paper and
it and and it goes into the vagina the
vagina
no it starts in the ass and then goes
into the vagina why does it know
that way that's what i'm saying like i
never saw it until i came to america and
i was in shock because i was like wait
who taught you that yeah who do you how
many people do you know that does that
and how
how do you know that about that and you
know what uh girls that i went to
nursing school with who are nurses now
who still wipe back to front that is so
weird
well you know like girls all congregate
in the bathroom like we go out we go
drinking or they go over to your house
we pee
together and you see those things and
you're like right
wow remember remember i made love to
that girl once and she had poo in her
ass i don't
remember i wasn't there oh yeah i told
you i told you the story
wait what happened why what happened
tell me everything i was i was doing
i was i was in la jolla and i was doing
her um
doggy style oh yeah this is the girl who
was like singing you love songs
she's really sweet i smell poo oh right
you know because you know you know the
smell of poo
yes right when you're doing it you're
like it's not sex smell it's poop i was
doing it
right you know and you look around when
you always look around you go where's
the move
right but then you i kept going i go
no that's definitely poo right and so i
i took my thumbs
right and i spread open her butt cheeks
and i looked and it was there was like a
long butt hair
yeah sticking out but at the tip of the
butt hair
there was a dingleberry it was old news
yeah it looked like a mushroom it wasn't
a fresh poo
yeah yeah and so i i tried to
you know what i mean you touched it no i
tried to flick it
oh dude i tried to flick it because
that's
you know i mean i still came would you
have you did i still came i still came
did you leave yeah oh i feel like i
would have maybe wrapped it up
was she attracted a girl in her ass
yes today i was on i was on twitter
yesterday and i saw that odell beckham
was trending
and i you know who will be still grossed
out by that story i'm taking a minute to
recover
yeah um but he's a football player yeah
he's a wide receiver right
yeah yeah he played for the cleveland
browns so basically
one of his ex-lovers came out and said
that he likes to be [ __ ] on
hell yeah yeah why would you say that
publicly
i don't know but she was on no jumper
and she said that
he he likes like really unshowered
coochie and he likes to be
um pooped on yeah some people are into
that
i don't know why that's poo i thought
you were into poo
you like to smell it yeah he sniffs our
dog's poos
oh gross bobby i hate the smell of their
poop
you put it right up to your nose i
really hate it no no no listen
why it's it's not like i go
i i don't do that that's the asian adult
bobby i like to smell horrible things
huh okay i like to smell horrible things
that's a like why would you smell
poop yes he does so he when he knows i'm
going in
and i try to lock the door he he fishes
the lock
goes right up to me in the toilet and he
goes
so yeah baby to anyone who says you're a
gold digger
remember what this relationship is
and know that it's real yeah it's not
only that like you know how many
underwear she sees like brown [ __ ]
nothing
not even a stain it's clumps of [ __ ] in
my underwear
bobby why why are you [ __ ] your body
i have a leaky ass like my dad
wait you have a leaky ass yeah my dad
you sharked a lot
no so my dad when my okay so my my
brother
when he was 11 years old had a friend
over
and they were playing this casio kind of
keyboard thing
you know and my dad was taking a nap
okay so my dad when he wake my dad from
a nap he gets violent
so my dad ran into my brother's room but
my dad was completely naked because he
sleeps naked
he took the case casio keyboard and
smashed it on my brother's head
keys were flying all over the place
right and when he turned around to leave
he had toilet paper sticking out of his
[ __ ]
right and that's when we realized that
my dad puts toilet paper in his [ __ ]
and later when my
later in life i asked why he does that
he goes and my mom said that he went to
the doctor he has a leaky [ __ ]
right so i that i feel like i have pain
yeah
i have a very leaky [ __ ] i don't know
which part is more disturbing the
beating or the your dad's [ __ ] being
corked with toilet paper
it's the the [ __ ] the [ __ ] the
beating was a normal thing
the beating was a normal thing very
violent in my home
you know look at now now you stuff
toilet paper up your ass
do you stuff toilet paper up your
[ __ ] no no no no okay i literally
i i don't want to be like that so i just
let it flow he free bleed
oh my god yeah i do yeah but if you're
if your diet is good wouldn't the turds
be like
because i feel like it would only leak
if you had like diarrhea right
oh my god it's if your diet is good that
doesn't necessarily mean that your app
your [ __ ] is going to be [ __ ]
always solid oh
well i did yeah bobby if i can interject
do you do you or do you not have a pizza
refrigerator
i do but you know do you think that has
anything to do with your leaky [ __ ]
i might maybe maybe maybe maybe but
those are the reasons why
i want to tell the guys that accuse her
for being with me because i you know
right it's like she has to see
right and experience the worst human
atrocities
yeah that one can see right and she's
still with me
no it's like he's beautiful my foot
fungi my [ __ ] stains you know what i
mean
absolutely so but it's
kaleilas still with me but
i i do but i kind of like even though i
in that moment i don't like that it's
happening
i i do like that you're playful in that
way like that's what i'm attracted to is
that
he's so just not by the book about
anything and he's such a
human tornado that i i feel really drawn
to that
um to that storm can i ask you so you'll
be taking a dump and bobby is pick
locking the lock
while you're taking a dump uh-huh and do
you say anything what do you say to him
like stop
don't come in and bobby's screaming stop
don't come in
and then every time and i'm trying to i
need it
if poop is halfway up my butt i just
chance it and do a half stand up to try
to close
the door oh my gosh um and so you're
taking it
the door was open he would just come
hang out with you inside
yeah wow
deep inhales like she doesn't she
doesn't fart in front of me
or any of that kind of stuff and
everyone sh like twice a year i'll out
here i'll hear a fart from you
but that stuff doesn't turn me off she
thinks it's going to turn me off
i don't think anything of it it's just
awesome what are you gonna
yeah well i don't think it's going to
turn you off i just prefer
not to there's this whole house already
smells like [ __ ] i'm
i'm trying not to contribute more to the
to the overall aroma
of our lives but i want to go back
yeah so bob bobby have you gotten really
good at pick locking that bathroom door
uses a safety pin and it's one of those
things where there's a little hole
right and you just put the pin in and it
opens it
yeah and then and then he comes in and
puts his head between your legs like in
the bowl
no man oh okay you just come out oh i'm
a
serial killer okay so you just come hang
out and bask in the smell
i just come into the bathroom right and
i go
i do a big sniff so i can just see if
you know she's healthy or not
and then i leave he does this thing
where he pretends to not enjoy it he's
like ooh
ooh yeah yeah and also if i'm like
if i'm taking a nap and i'm on my side
he'll
ambush he'll come in and just spread the
cheeks and try to take a deep breath you
put your nose in her [ __ ] and sniff
bro what's the weirdest thing what's the
weirdest smell you like
i like um
like a dead bird oh no i don't like the
birds that's really sad i don't like
that
what's wrong with you
i think it did i think just death in
general
like a dead bird so you went up you
found a dead rotting dead bird and you
sniffed
the [ __ ] out of it well do you remember
the bird that died in the backyard
yeah it didn't smell like anything did
you smell it up close
no i did yeah it didn't smell good i
don't think you should be sniffing birds
in the age of a pandemic
so i i made a i've got a shoe box that's
why they call it kung flu because you
look at this [ __ ] dead bird
so it's cool i took the shoe box and i
put the dead bird in the shoe box
and i put like remember i made it nice
like a little bedding yeah we made a we
had a burial yeah before i because i
taped it up too but before i did that i
went
i smelled it i hated it but that means
you liked it right
yeah i hated it and then i closed it
back up and i taped it
we buried it i like the smell of
um you know when you have a earring hole
oh and when you press
on it and the little stuff comes out if
you've been very easy
yeah sorry what i didn't this is i
didn't know about this
yeah the [ __ ] they're [ __ ] in your ear
hole yeah it's like
it's like sharp cheddar but it's very um
addicting like you just it's very an
intriguing smell do you get that behind
your ear ever
because i know a smell behind my ear
that smells like that
i don't get in behind my hair just in
the actual ear hole if i push on it in a
little
you know about that smelly hair just to
me because i rarely wear
earrings you have cheese in your ear
hole so i feel like sometimes when i do
put
the earring in after a long time it kind
of gets irritated
and then afterwards when i take it out
and there's like that
kind of that smell you smell that bobby
no i want to yeah you should i'm i'm i'm
glad you said it because i really want
to smell it oh
gladly can you do it right now no no no
i don't have any right now only when
like says when it gets yeah
yeah what other weird smells girls have
do you ever scratch your vagina and
smell your hand
what would you ask that i'm kidding
i have a lot of curiosity well then
check it out for yourself
yes ethan um it was good to see that's
it i mean
that's pretty much it is there anything
else no
i mean i mean i i could honestly
probably do another two hours one day i
think so
i mean how long have we gone together
two hours two hours two hours
yeah i love you guys yeah i love you too
guys
we love you guys hopefully after the
pandemic i'd like to see you guys in
flesh
that would be nice i know mm-hmm dry
days are you guys seeing anybody at all
dude i'm getting so sick of it i'm
getting so
[ __ ] sick of it dude i just want to
like
also i feel so bad for theodore because
he's he's this young vibrant
boy who wants who should be out looking
at the zoo
and socializing with kids and he's happy
at home he doesn't know what he's
missing but like
it's it's it's just it's tough it's
getting tough
yeah it'll it'll pass but i ain't
playing a lot of video games at night
what are you playing lately
i play a lot of warzone you know that um
what's her name yoko ono has a song
called warzone that's really funny
not really yeah you should hear the game
though is it
no what do you play what do you what do
you play ethan i just been playing
like super little games like i've been
playing hollow knight
you know that game oh no
i'm sure it's good i don't like
multiplayer games it's too stressful
yeah yeah i get to i get too competitive
and and the problem is i get competitive
and also i'm not good
yeah i'm not good either but you know
warzone you have an xbox or
a station so warzone and um
um it's all across all platforms like if
you have a playstation i have an xbox we
can still
hold on the there's probably some i
don't know if you can hear the dogs
oh we'll just we'll just end it here i
love you
okay that's it bye bobby love you thank
you all right i love you
and bye take care